calling the military seizure of power
a direct assault on myanmar's transition
to democracy
u.s president joe biden issued a stern
warning to the country's military
leaders
reverse course or face economic
sanctions
we removed sanctions the united states i
should say remove sanctions on burma
over the past decade based on
progress toward democracy the reversal
of that progress will necessitate an
immediate review
of our sanctions laws and authorities
followed by appropriate action
the white house is calling on the
international community
to pressure myanmar's military to
immediately release detained officials
and relinquish the powers it seized the
developments are a test for the
fledgling biden administration
and the new secretary of state anthony
blinken
who was sworn in last week the top
republican in the senate mitch mcconnell
released this statement pressuring the
biden administration
to take a strong stand and urging u.s
partners and all democracies around the
world to follow suit
in condemning this authoritarian assault
on democracy
when biden was vice president barack
obama became the first sitting u.s
president to visit myanmar he praised
its steps toward democratic and
economic reform strict u.s sanctions
against the country were lifted
when myanmar transitioned to civilian
rule but
u.s support for myanmar's government
began to sour because of its
discrimination
against rohingya muslims that included a
denial of citizenship
there were further concerns when
civilian leader aung san tsuchi
defended the military as hundreds of
thousands fled
as refugees the foreign policy crisis
comes as the biden administration is
struggling to deal with domestic issues
like a depressed economy and
unemployment due to the global covet 19
pandemic
that's cost roughly 450 000
americans their lives it's still trying
to get its sea legs and still trying to
figure out what its foreign policies
will be
and most importantly it's um very
preoccupied with domestic crises the
biden administration really wants to
focus on the pandemic and on economic
crisis at home
and on racial tensions and it really
doesn't
i think it's not ready to have to
confront a crisis like this
the biden administration faces a dilemma
tough u.s measures could push myanmar's
military rulers
closer to china a u.s adversary
something the new president wants to
avoid
kimberly hellcat al jazeera washington